five four three two one
engines full power
and lifts off Falcon nine go action
copy one alpha together we expand what
is possible in low earth orbit add Astra
and Godspeed ax2
plus 36 seconds 36 seconds into flight
a great view of Falcon 9 into space
down
power Telemetry novel three big sequence
and a view live of the crew inside
dragon
they're getting ready we're gonna get
three events here main engine
separation confirmed
copy two alpha
[Applause]
and back ignition
stage one blue Speck startup
you can stage engine the first stage is
into the Boost back burn working its way
back
waiting for call out that the Boost back
burn is complete
there you go
you can see that first stage has landed
back at lz1